will former vice president Mike Pence  now says that the constitution does not  actually guarantee freedom from religion  well the radical left believes the  freedom of religion is the freedom from  religion  but it's nothing the American Founders  ever thought of or generations of  Americans fought to defend unfortunately  he's wrong and it does there's really  two critical Parts here there's Congress  shall make no law prohibiting the free  exercise of religion and then there's  part two which is Congress shall make no  law respecting an establishment of  religion if you cannot establish a  religion you can't establish religion  generally and thus you cannot infringe  upon freedom from religion Penn says  usual is wrong and remember we're  supposed to believe he's good now  because he didn't try to steal the  election in 2020 which by the way he  couldn't have done anyway this guy's  pathetic